[Música]
eu quero falar sobre quatro ideias que
merecem ser compartilhadas com vocês
muito bem e eu digo essas idéias não
porque eu acredito que vão trazer uma
satisfação pessoal pra mim mas
simplesmente porque eu acredito que
essas idéias podem trazer um significado
pra a minha comunidade onde eu vi
primeiro quero falar sobre o poder da
mudança uma mudança que eu fiz em 2010
segundo eu quero falar sobre o poder das
lições da minha mãe antes de aparecer
que mudou a minha personalidade me fez
enxergar o mundo
eu digo maravilhoso um terceiro pode ser
estranho mas eu quero falar de novo
sobre o poder da mudança em 2016 que eu
fiz
por fim não é porque é o menos
importante
pelo contrário eu quero falar sobre a
aplicação dessas mudanças todas e das
lições da minha mãe
como vocês podem perceber eu não sou
alguém aqui há de vir aqui o som de onde
eu sou eu sou do haiti perfeito eu sou
empreendedor social o meu trabalho é
ajudar as pessoas que não têm moradias
eu ajudo essas pessoas isso convém dizer
que eu sou engenheiro civil ter feito
bom eu quero que você se coloquem no
lugar por favor pessoal não imagina que
você está fora do seu país estudando
trabalhando ou visitando de repente no
dia 12 de janeiro
de 2010 você viu na televisão um na
internet
a capital do seu país foi destruída por
um terremoto
eu digo na escada 7.2 como antes de você
perguntar pra mim eu pergunto pra vocês
como você se sentiria momento desse 300
mil motos não significa de cerca de 37
anos
um estava a moto mais de 250 mil pessoas
desabrigadas
a cada 46 haitianos um estava sem teto
eu digo muito mais danos materiais a
mais de dois milhões de pessoas um
prejuízo em torno de 7.8 bilhões de
dólares acima do pib em 2009 muito bem
estou dizendo isso pessoal eu me lembro
como se fosse ontem esse dia que estava
no alojamento da universidade federal do
rio de janeiro
cursou odontologia eu falei pra mim uma
frase essa frase eu me lembro como se
fosse ontem
é sempre assim é o propósito nem pessoal
considerei o desafio de fazer engenharia
na ufrj
eu tirei 0,5 em cálculo 1
na verdade mas pra mim isso era um
detalhe quando você tem um propósito num
puzzle asmo
você sabe por que você faz alguma coisa
você supera os desafios com maestria
bom eu filmei um propósito quando entrei
na engenharia
eu tentei girar uma roda muito simples
a primeira coisa que eu fui fazer a
engenharia para poder voltar vai te
ajudar eu queria me envolver em casa já
participar muito bem então eu comecei a
entender o solo não acredita o sono em
qualquer lugar do mundo você tem só
precisa saber quem ele é
é um solo que tem mais areia aí no uso é
um solo que tem mais rígida a generoso
sabendo isso eu poderia fazer um tijolo
muito simples em qualquer lugar do mundo
muito bem
não adianta só fazer o tesouro de solo
mais cimento
é preciso entender você está falando do
haiti que entre duas placas tectônicas
e você também está em uma região que é a
bacia do caribe que potencializa ainda
se krones furacões e 7
então precisava reforçar essas
estruturas
eu me lembro como se fosse ontem na
universidade
pesquisando andando pensando mas todo
feliz porque estava com um propósito é
eu comecei a entender a dinâmica você
começar a construir com boas práticas
para alguém que não tem recurso
financeiro e você trazer essas boas
práticas
por exemplo você olha uma estrutura onde
tem abertura é um ponto fraco
eu fiquei incomodado quando hondo noite
todo eu vejo as casas construídas de
forma muito bem
eu achei entendendo essa dinâmica eu
poderia dar uma pequena contribuição
diante de tomar grande de destruição do
país
foi então que comecei a entender bom se
você entendeu tesouro saber construir
com ele e depois disso você precisa ter
recursos para pessoas que não têm
recursos
então a gente entendeu que seria o
regime de mutirão ajuda mútua
neste caso alan poderia ajudar o mundo o
homem de poder ajudar tereza e vamos
fazer algo de formar um participativo
isso admira muito a construção de uma
casa popular numa família não tem
recurso muito bem então seria difícil ou
a não saber construir uma casa inteira
desde a fundação até acabamento
então seria muito mais interessante é
você tentar desenvolver esses projetos
prontos para fazer sua fundação ajuri a
fazer só é colocar tijolos por josa
eu acho incrível eu ando muito feliz eu
faço algo que eu acredito que pode fazer
a diferença na vida de muita gente muito
bem então essa roda encaixaria muito bem
estou falando estava em 2015 e início de
então eu fui buscar algumas idéias em
cingapura o guardian o brasil e outros
países
foi então eu comecei a entender tá bom
então você vai construir uma casa de
baixo custo sustentável - é mais muito
bem a roda girando eu estava muito feliz
em 2006 parou parou de funcionar roda
eu me lembro como se fosse ontem quando
recebi uma ligação do haiti dizendo que
minha mãe queria conversar comigo
mari é uma senhora amorosa sensível de
fazer quando durona
eu me lembro quando minha mãe falou pra
mim com uma voz muito suave que queria
me passar algumas lições e fala tudo bem
maria que foi meu filho eu quero que
você me prometa três coisas eu me
assustei porque minha mãe nunca fala
assim comigo ia falar a primeira coisa
que eu quero que você me prometa sempre
buscar fazer a coisa certa entregar
valor materiais tudo bem você precisa me
prometer isto
a segunda coisa que eu quero que você me
prometa é você vai valorizar cada vez
mais a educação
minha mãe gostava de dizer que a
educação talvez não seja a solução mas
qualquer solução necessariamente precisa
passar pela educação e até ser uma coisa
minha mãe falou pra mim que ela existiu
muito e ela falou já quem você precisa
um dia independentemente onde você
estiver
voltar para a sua comunidade bom a
conversa acabou assim minha mãe falou
pra mim já que eu preciso descansar
porque estou muito mal
minha mãe sofreu o diabetes
eu liguei pro meu pai no dia seguinte
dizendo minha mãe teve uma conversa
muito dramática comigo meu pai é muito
durona viu e ele falam só uma frase
a única coisa que você precisa fazer já
que
o perseguia as lições da sua mãe a maior
ciência a experiência
meu pai nunca fui para a escola nunca
estudou mas ele teve a sabedoria dizer
que maior ciência é experiência bom
foi então é eu voltei para a
universidade eu comecei a pesquisar cada
vez mais sobre a tecnologia só de
cimento conversando com outras colegas
três dias depois a marin
minha mãe faleceu um foi dramático ali
como que uma senhora e aparecer dando
três lições dessa forma algo acontecendo
pessoal à vida bate de vez em quando com
tijolo na sua cabeça
eu espero da final dessa parece a
mostrar pra vocês
você pode fazer algo diferente com
tijolo e tabaco na sua cabeça
eu recebi a notícia a minha pequena
comunidade dom do limite foi o terceiro
a ter sua ideia que eu queria
compartilhar com vocês destruiu
inteiramente aqui eu queria que vocês
tirarem uma foto dessa imagem com a da
mente de vocês
então eu liguei pro meu irmão dizendo
que eu queria voltar depois de tudo isto
eu comecei a entender a primeira coisa
minha vida é a forma que você consegue
achar um sentido um propósito para sua
vida às vezes me parece é olhar pra trás
conectar os pontos
eu coloquei o ponto terremoto
minha mãe transmissões furacão
eu falei que eu voltar e ajudar minha
pequena comunidade como a terceira
edição da minha mãe seria sempre voltar
muito bem eu liguei para o meu irmão
dizendo que eu ia voltar e ele falou pra
mim não seria inteligente você voltar eu
falei vou aí minha mãe meu irmão falou
eu entendo o que você quer voltar à
minha família é muito grande 11 filhos
em uma fala o seguinte é porque a mamãe
marie
lu três missões para todos nós
pessoal estou dizendo isso não porque eu
acredito que isso é uma virtude
estou dizendo tudo isso porque eu
acredito no poder da identidade
quem você é quando alguém cita seu nome
o medo é alguém de confiança então eu
nunca fiz nada do contrário dessas
transmissões e nesse momento eu tô vendo
tudo isso para poder contar algo mais
especial foi então no final do meu curso
de engenharia na ufrj eu falei então eu
vou reconstruir a minha pequena
comunidade é difícil né você entender a
tecnologia você recusar propostas de
trabalho trabalhei fazer algo maior do
que você que o propósito minha mãe antes
de falecer disso no meu coração
então eu queria perguntar pra vocês se
vocês se fosse no meu lugar
a espécie que dá um nome criar uma
organização para ajudar as pessoas
humildes
qual o nome que você daria essa
organização virada com parceria é feito
pessoal
a associação grande uma organização que
nós criamos com a idéia de ajudar as
pessoas humildes que eu acho incrível a
com sua própria casa
a teresa foi a primeira pessoa a ser
entrevistada como você gostaria de com
sua casa em regime de mutirão não teresa
onde vem o brasil falou pra mim já que
eu vá e volte
então eu fiz questão de entender como
ela pensava
alguém lembra dessa fotografia por favor
perfeito
isso é o nice eu espero um dia alguns de
vocês possam conhecer a ele e ele me
mandou essa porta pra mim em 2006 sendo
que a nossa pequena unidade foi
destruída não tem mais esperança porque
eu acredito com a esperança
você anda eu falei que tem esperança
eu peguei a fotografia e eu fiz assim eu
vou mostrar algo pra vocês pra ver o
porteiro propósito
peguei isto escrever um livro você
percebe e hoje estamos na terceira
edição podendo voltar agora para
reconstruir iniciar com recurso também
este livro enquanto poderia não voltar
seria de esperança muito bem então o
universo dessas pessoas
dessa forma pessoal e vivem bom eu
queria agora fazer uma viagem com vocês
o que consiste na associação virá de
marketing
basicamente eu poderia pedir para vocês
feche por favor nos olhos de vocês vamos
viajar por aí pessoal podemos é feito
então imagina você vive no espaço
você vive sozinho na sua própria o sol
própria casa onde se assim em um barraco
que não é casa e você compartilha suas
idéias culturas no seu próprio tributo e
ceto e de repente alguém chega e dizer
pra você você precisa sair desse ponto
isolado
vamos para um lugar ou julgado que esse
é um village onde você pode olhar pedra
que vira o elemento voz é fazer a
fundação e o solo pode virar o elemento
a fazer o tijolo ecológico e eu te
capacita um eu te ensina a fazer algo eu
te ensina a fazer a fundação eu te
ensinou a colocar o seu jorge disse joão
vicente jogos
você não vai construir apenas um país e
com um sonho
de repente você selecione nesse universo
15 pessoas
quinze famílias pra morar nessas
primeiras 15 casas e aí você consegue
antigamente você tinha que pegar um
balde e buscar água e quilômetros
você tinha que sair da sua casa e no
banheiro porque nunca tinha isto então
exatamente isso que ouvirá de maio vocês
entendem a idéia tem um estudo que
mostrou que a cada 3 pobres dois vivem
em região rural
significa dizer você tem que conectar
essas pessoas
inovações sociais para ajudar essas
pessoas então não adiantava só casa você
tinha que conjugar este espaço com
outros equipamentos públicos como
escolas igreja creche e seta em seu
modelo de um virage autossustentável é
isso que nós fazemos de viragem barril
muito bem então vocês entendem porque a
casa do village é diferente
não é porque você faz um tijolo
ecológico porque você capacita as
pessoas
cada um faz com se o próprio mão você
pega o elemento você com sua seu próprio
sonho é autoestima empoderamento então
por isso esse muro da casa raimundo
diferença
estamos indo agora para o haiti para
iniciar as construções para fazer cinco
casas com recursos do livro e com outras
pessoas aqui é algo muito especial e é
muito simples de fazer e eu no segmento
a nossa ferramenta que nós trabalhamos
eu trouxe aqui inclusive ele é muito é
podendo compartilhar com vocês pela
primeira vez que estou buscando isso na
verdade é porque o propósito foi o
primeiro elemento que eu conseguir fazer
uns com outros amigos na oratória e eu
acho isso tão especial então eu queria
dividir esse projeto com vocês
alguém sabe o que tem lá dentro é uma
pessoa muito inteligente aqui
bom pessoal a ideia é essa então e é
algo muito simples de fazer e é você
pode manusear ele e você sabe
intuitivamente o que fazer com ele
então eu queria dizer pra vocês
não importa o que você tem na sua mão o
que me importa é o que você faz com ele
eu sei que vocês estão com um smartphone
na mão de vocês mas eu quero dizer pra
vocês
temos que conectar também com as pessoas
porque a nossa humanidade precisa cada
vez mais humanidades
eu acredito que vamos se é como seres
humanos evoluídos
quando nós somos capazes de ajudar o
próximo em entender que o outro tem um
direito humano e ainda atividade humana
para respeitar muito obrigado pessoal
[Aplausos]